what do you make of the battle of wards
between senator rand paul and dr anthony
fauci over this particular point
i don't want to talk about specific
members of congress but i will say it's
really unfortunate that tony fauci who
is the epitome of a dedicated public
servant
has now somehow been targeted for
political reasons
as somebody that
certain figures are trying to discredit
perhaps to try to distract from their
own failings
this never should have happened here's a
person who's dedicated his whole life
to trying to prevent illnesses from
infectious diseases including hiv
in the 1980s and 90s and now
probably the most
knowledgeable infectious disease
physician in the world and also a really
good communicator
is out there telling the truth about
where we are with sarsko v2
to certain political figures who don't
want to hear it and who are therefore
determined to discredit him and that is
disgraceful so with politicians there
they often play games with black and
white
they try to sort of use
the gray areas of science and then paint
their own picture
but i have a question about the gray
areas of science so like you mentioned
gain of function is a term that's very
specific scientific meaning
but it also has a more general term and
it's very possible to argue that the
not to argue not the way politicians
argue but just as human beings and
scientists that there was a gain of
function achieved
at the wuhan institute of biology
but it didn't cross a threshold i mean
there's a it's it's uh it but it could
have too
so here's the thing when you do these
kinds of experiments
unexpected
results may be achieved and that's the
gray area of science you're you're
taking risks with such experiments
and i am very uncomfortable that we
can't
discuss the uncertainty in the gray area
of this
oh i'm comfortable discussing the gray
area what i'm uncomfortable with is
people deciding to define for themselves
what that threshold is based on sort of
some political argument the threshold
was very explicitly laid out
everybody agreed to that
in the basis of this three years of
deliberation so that's what it is if
that threshold needs to be reconsidered
let's reconsider it but let's not try to
take an experiment that's already been
done and decide that the threshold isn't
what it was because that that really is
doing a disservice to the whole process
i wish there was a discussion even in
response to
rand paul and i know we're not talking
about specific senators but just that
particular case i'm saying stuff here i
wish there's an opportunity to talk
about
given the current threshold this is not
gain of function
but maybe we need to reconsider the
threshold and have an action that's an
opportunity for discussion about the
ethics of gain and function you said
that there was three studies that passed
that threshold with influenza that's a
fascinating human question scientific
question about ethics because
you're playing like you said there's uh
there's pros and cons
you're taking risks here to prevent
horribly destructive viruses in the
future
but you also
are risking creating such viruses in the
future with nuclear weapons and nuclear
energy
you are
nuclear energy
promises a lot of positive effects and
yet you're taking risks here with uh
mutually sure destruction of nations
possessing nuclear weapons oh my
you're
alive i hope we're not going in there
well we're not but
a lot of people argue that that's the
reason we've nuclear weapons is the
reason we've prevented world wars
and yet they also have the risk of
starting world wars and this is what we
have to be honest about
with the with the benefits of risks of
science that you have to
make that calculation of what are the
pros and what are the cons i'm totally
with you but i want to reassure you lex
that this is not an issue that's been
ignored yes that this issue about the
kind of gain of function that might
result in a serious human pathogen has
been front and center in many
deliberations for a decade or more
involved a lot of my time along the way
by the way
and has been discussed publicly on
multiple occasions including two major
meetings of the national academy of
sciences
getting input from everybody and
ultimately arriving at our current
framework now
we actually back in january of 2020 just
before covet 19 changed everything
had planned and even charged that same
national
uh
science advisory by board on biosecurity
to reconvene and look at the current
framework and say do we have it right
let's look at the experience over those
three years and say is the threshold too
easy too hard
do we need to reconsider it let's look
at the experience kovit came along the
members of the board said please we're
all infectious disease experts we don't
have time for this right now but i think
the time is right to do this i'm totally
supportive of that and that should be
just as public a discussion as you can
imagine about what are the benefits and
the risk and if somebody decided
ultimately this came together and said
we just shouldn't be doing these
experiments under any circumstances if
that was the conclusion well that would
be the conclusion but it hasn't been so
far
you